my name is Isaiah James I'm a rock war
veteran I went two times to Iraq also
went once in Afghanistan my job in the
Army was 11 Bravo for those who don't
know that's infantry my additional skill
identifier is Bravo 4 for those who
don't know that is a sniper first
deployment was 15 months second
deployment was 12 months third
deployment was 12 months so I've been
there 39 months of combat straight
fighting I could take a rifle and clear
a room and do all this crazy stuff I've
air assaulted out of helicopters I've
grabbed dudes and put bags over their
heads and zip tied them and put them on
helicopters and saw them being flown
away and they've never seen the game
the Iraq war did not need to happen it
should not have happened Iraq did
nothing to us and we killed a million
Iraqi civilians lost 5 000 plus American
soldiers for what it diminished our
standing in the world it standed
bankrupted our coffers all it did was
make the war machine get bigger and
stronger in America I think anybody
who's been shot at and blown up and seen
people blown to literal pieces is
anti-war if you're not and this is for
I'm speaking directly to every veteran
out there if you love war then you've
never actually been in it if you I don't
give a damn if you sir you've never seen
somebody take their last breath in a
violent situation you've never seen I
have it's not pretty